hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge sims
4 mir wurden unglaublich viele
kommentare wieder geschrieben dass ich
das ganze wieder zocken sollen wir
wurden tipps gegeben wie ich eine party
machen kann
deshalb wir werden heute eine party
machen hier sind wir schon nicht hat
einfach mal fortsetzen drücken dann
sehen wir schon geht das ganze weiter
ich glaube waren das letzte mal dass
stehen liegen dass die sich alle unter
dem baum hier vorne unterhalten hat
ach sind das wieder tolle unterhaltung
hier mir wurde oft gesagt ich kann
einfach bei dem typ mir auf der loukas
louka war er geht ich dachte wir jetzt
mit diesem mann irgendwo privatsphäre
suchen
sie setzt sich einfach da vorne hin
bevor wir das ganze planen
da muss ich irgendwie auf das handy
klicken oder so gibt es noch drei sachen
die ich ganz gut sagen muss es geht
wirklich ganz schnell ich kann mich ganz
schnell machen ich kann also schnell das
ja nicht immer gut es gibt ja auch paar
sachen wo man erstens geht am
allerschnellsten ich bin krank deswegen
ist meine stimme heiser und ich bitte
das zu entschuldigen zweite sache wenn
ihr das video gerade seht es mittwoch
ich bin am samstagabend auf pro 7 20.15
der völkerball wm was ich bin samstag
abend auf prosieben von 20.15 bis
irgendwann abends und die spiele
völkerball zusammen mit kesha und kelly
und sarah zwar und schaltet ein und
support-team internet oder wie wir
heißen
ich weiß ich bin krank aber ich bin
trotzdem seien also samstagabend
prosieben und supported mich irgendwie
inwiefern das eeg das könnte sache am 23
04 ist ein fantreffen in wien wenn ihr
in wien wohnen oder österreich oder so
und ihr bock habt mich zu treffen und
ein autogramm von mir zu bekommen dann
seid am 23.04
in wien findet einen link ganz oben in
der beschreibung darüber gibt es gibt
nur 150 tickets
also wenn ihr das hier gerade hört
klickt am besten auf den link drauf und
versucht noch ein zu bekommen ich kann
nicht versprechen dass noch welche da
sind es kostet glaube ich zehn euro aber
ihr bekommt dafür ein rucksack und
verzehrgutschein und alles also
letztendlich bezahlt eigentlich nicht ja
also kauft über den link in der
beschreibung und mit viel glück kriegt
noch ein ticket aber es sind echt nicht
wieder da seid schnell und das wird ein
cooles fern treffen am 23 04
und jetzt ist es die drei sitzen hier
unten schön auf der bank da flattern
schmetterlinge vorher und wickeln können
jetzt einfach mal hier auf das handy
klicken oder können wir du kannst kein
gesellschaftliches ereignis planen wenn
du nicht begrüßt wirst wie kann wie kann
ich denn begrüßt werden
ich reise jetzt mit luca einfach mal
nach hause in unserer gekauftes haus
nebenan
mir wurde nämlich selbst in die
kommentare geschrieben dass ich quasi
über das handy irgendwie diese
gesellschaftlichen ereignisse planen
kann bzw eine party planen kann aber
irgendwie ist es geht gesellschaftliches
ereignis planen jetzt wirklich drauf
natürlich 37 bezahlt und der nutzer
massiv
der schwarzweiß party inkognito
kostümparty hausparty gala abend eine
hausparty wir doch lies aber ein hotdog
ist natürlich auch dass ich manchmal
einfach eine hausparty lade jetzt kinder
da luca droht luca hat luca natürlich
luca gastgeber sein max und luca dann
haben
als gast auf jeden fall dem johnny
schwarzes in gast- und dann haben wir
jetzt noch ein entertainer mixa und
caterer deswegen mache jetzt einfach mal
dass wir das bei die schwarz residenz
von johnny cash war die ware das schön
bei uns zu hause kriegen doch fällig und
jetzt ist luca party outfit angezogen
jan-luca dann geh jetzt schön hier hin
was ich weiß jetzt auch gar nicht wo
inwiefern startet jetzt die party wenn
ich über dem kopf von max besteht dort
gastgeber über den kopf von luca steht
auch das geber diese wissen lieber die
haben da genau das gleiche anwidert oder
max und luca partner lot ist witzig und
max hat sogar noch einen käsekuchen hier
dann esse ich das einfach mal von max
auf ich glaube dass hier soll die
hausparty darstellen oder vorne sitzen 2
oder 8 das ist doch johnny ja genau die
schwarzen sind gas dann habe ich hier
die anderen die eric lewis des
gastgebers ihr tier nicht noch irgendwie
warten können die nicht irgendwie jetzt
mal kinder machen oder alkohol trinken
oder irgendwie mal was hier 80 hier ist
doch alkohol luke adam hähnchenflügel t
ich werde nicht mehr luca bestellt sich
natürlich wieder das teuerste getränk
und zwar feuersbrunst und wird jetzt im
aufwind einem star luca läuft zum
caterer und bestellt sich einen drink
der drink wird gemacht die tante puls
rein
er ist ein typ es ist einfach ein typ
der typ macht jan richtig krassen
cocktail hier gerade für mich als
ausländer raus luca holt sich sein feuer
bruns bring cup setzt sich dorthin und
die konzentriert trinken dass er außer
das ding gebrannt ich weiß nicht aber
ich glaube luca ist echt schon irgendwie
leicht betrunken der trend ihre ganze
zeit hinterher schon wieder ein stück
raus max sitzt einfach da hinten ganz
alleine auf der party und ist total
langweilig und was hat er denn orange
jade mit pfiff ja plötzlich neben ein
mädel und muss unbedingt pinkeln und
denkt die ganze zeit ans bett und kann
aber was ist denn das für ein scheiß
party jetzt steht er vor dem mädel und
winkt rum und muss auf toilette dann
jedoch verdammte scheiße auf toilette du
läufst auch schon noch um die sonne
totaler euro geht luca er geht
tatsächlich ach kommt einmal auf die
idee auf toilette zu gehen das ist ja
wundervoll ich spule die zeit gerade
schon vor und lukas immer noch total die
ganze zeit einfach nur fachkundig und
jetzt erstmals erstmal was macht er
jetzt wird er nimmt seinen drink setzt
sich hin zu den mädels und trägt
natürlich wieder das ist der luga wie
man überall wo luca hingeht beklagen
sich über stinkende schuhe und ihr ach
guck mal hallo max das ist warum mach
dir nichts draus luca du bist kein opfer
gierig anderen handy alles klar dass es
das ist doch gar kein problem max kommt
gerade an mit einem drink will sich zu
luca luka ist anders wenn luca du bist
nicht du wirst jetzt nicht
ich glaube die partys damit beendet ich
habe halt nicht so gedacht zu jaulen
sims könnte man locker eine richtige
party veranstalten letztendlich liegt
luca im bett und hat auch irgendwie sich
keine opfer erst fertig und luca wird
wieder ins bett und ist wieder am start
und träumt von hähnchen
damit würde ich das video an dieser
stelle auch beenden ich wollte eine
heiße party machen
letztendlich ging total nach hinten los
und die party war die schlimmste phase
die sims hier gesehen hat war war sehr
traurig wenn es euch gefallen habe ich
mich über eine bewertung volles tut mir
leid dass meine stimme am arsch sind das
video vielleicht nicht so viel
gearbeitet ist wie sonst auch immer dass
wir doch in den nächsten vier videos
nicht anlass sein weil ich einfach total
fertig bin und sehr viel stress der zeit
habe und ja aber auf jeden fall unten in
der beschreibung ist ein link wo ihr
ticket kaufen können vielleicht sind
auch schon alle weg ich weiß nicht mit
ihr schauen ob wir da vielleicht mal
welche bekommt in wien für den 23 04
aber sonst erst mal am samstag prosieben
einschalten da werde ich sein